total war maker creative assembly might
not be the first studio you think of
when it comes to survival horror but
trust me when I say that alien isolation
is one of the most terrifying games I
played in years I think it's close
Ricardo and if you're an alien fan
burned on the likes of aliens colonial
Marines and aliens vs. predator there's
a lot to be excited about
the starters alien isolation is based on
alien not aliens so there aren't stacks
of guns and explosives and corridors
packed with dozens of canine likes
animals in the demo I was shown I was
armed with nothing but a motion detector
and a prayer alien isolation is survival
horror and it's mostly NAND terrifying
form
there's not even a HUD overlay to break
immersion the story focuses on Ripley's
daughter Amanda who 15 years after last
seeing her mother is sent by whaling
attorney to recover the flight recorder
of the Nostromo aboard a remote trading
station naturally things go awry very
quickly the demo I played didn't reveal
much in the way of story
that everything else was very impressive
Creative Assembly has been carefully
curating stacks of original prop
schematics costume designs and audio
from the film and it shows in the game
it's suitably dark and moody yet pays
great homage to the film's Stark set
designs and loafie sci-fi tech and
there's even a fine grain to give it a
film like look the missions in the demo
was simple involving cutting through a
doorway with a plasma torch and hunting
down items while those items didn't have
a practical use in the demo I'm told
that the crafting system is making its
way into the game letting you craft
simple weapons and traps the main draw
of course is a xenomorph encounter and
the game did a wonderful job of ramping
up the tension mostly by simply not
showing the alien until you absolutely
needed to escape from it being armed
with nothing but a motion detector but
there was a real sense of dread and
urgency as I crawled my way through the
corridors constantly keeping my eye on
the little dock and listening to that
incessant beeping in order to try and
sneak past it
I was told the alien isn't on a scripted
path either with a sophisticated AI
meaning actively hunted down certainly I
never had the same experience twice and
hearing the thumps of the aliens feet
always blood-curdling house echoed
through the station was absolutely
terrifying there's so much tension that
you really don't want to actually see
the alien I was shaking when I left the
demo room and it's more than likely that
if you do see the thing you'll be on the
receiving end of some acidic drool and a
sharp pair of teeth it's an impressive
and terrifying start of an alien
isolation and I can't wait to see more
it's mostly enough to make me forget
entirely about the Sham that was aliens
colonial Marines mostly